ironic shirts this is not one of those
this is a true truth shirt how many did
you want to come on camera I'm good
okay stay friend for Steve Hollander
although it's done it's my show dad
hahaha I told me to keep my wall at my
front pocket so it doesn't hurt my back
and I don't and it has hurt my back over
what years oh look at this you seen Oh
Hannah be a open-water by the way there
we go
perfect um so coming up a little bit
later we are going to have some very
special people stopping by we're super
excited if you've seen our show you know
who they are
now here's the thing Oh Sona and David
are coming back in why what did you guys
forget they actually don't work here so
now it do that
well we're gonna play a game that's
pretty intense cuz we've done hidden
folks which is basically Where's Waldo
we did some animal crossing this is on
the next level this is on the next level
we're gonna you guys are gonna see the
true power of mobile gaming I'm very
excited about it oh boy I don't want to
load any game data okay um but before we
do that we're gonna take a look at a
clip of a person who we are very excited
to welcome but I can't do it yet can i
no we recycle it streams twitch back up
how's everybody doing yes Ramon that was
Sona we love Sona this is gonna be one
of many parts I think we're probably
gonna have to go back down and come back
up maybe four or five times because 24
hours is a long time I went outside I
saw the Sun it was beautiful I had an
hour off I spent it not talking which is
why my voice is so loud it's wow man we
got a lot special guests loaded up over
here
Nova najara it's only been I think three
hours which is why there's no tears on
my face yet we still we still we still
have oh we're back right just before we
I go to this clip I just want to say for
those of you who saw the beginning of
our stream Kona was here he was chewing
gum he took it out we've kept the gum
and we're keeping it the entire 24
that's right there it is it's gross so
we're gonna see if we can get a guest
not one of you guys in here to chew it
at some point so we're gonna see that's
my goal 24 hours to get a person not
Conan to chew this put it on this cap
Thank You Hollander look at that okay
how we feel we feel again yeah all right
great so without further ado we are
going to go watch a little clip let's
stand up clip from one of our very very
favorite people who's coming on next her
name is Moe Welch and this is a bit of
her comedy take a look so much for
having me I'm a little bit surprised to
be honest I don't think I'm supposed to
be a stand-up comedian so I'm sorry like
this isn't my childhood dream my
childhood dream was to be in the WNBA
yeah it's the NBA for her pleasure when
I was in seventh grade I got a women's
basketball for Christmas I immediately
realized I could palmate and I was like
alright blame ball for the rest of my
life my my voice is deep back then I
also realized that I have really large
hands for a female thanks you know what
they say about a lady with big hands
gross
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'm a FEMINIST I've that's good you'll
like this joke I've noticed a lot of
people are claiming to be feminists but
I don't think you're real feminists
unless you know all of the WNBA teams
you guys want to learn the WNBA teams I
mean we're here alright here they are LA
Sparks in New York Liberty Minnesota
Lynx and Phoenix Mercury Indiana Fever
Dallas Wings and San Antonio stars medic
and son Seattle storm Atlanta dream in
Chicago's guy if you put all the teams
in a singing list you become a feminist
thank you
also the Washington Mystics they don't
fit that song I'm a professional singer
you guys want to marry your mom when you
were younger
all right I wanted to marry my mom so
hard because when you're younger adults
say when you get older you're gonna
marry who you love and I was like well I
love mom there we go
cue the wedding bells and that's a cute
and innocent thought at least it was
until my parents got a divorce it was
back on the table my siblings would walk
by I'm like hey did mom say anything
about me always flirting with me making
me dinner picking me up dropping me off
not to be gay but I'm a lesbian thank
you that's actually the first time I've
ever said that so thank you so much yeah
I was like you know what I'm gonna come
out when I can get to Burbank in front
of a studio audience in front of Conan
and Auntie and Molly
I'm a gay and I'm Irish and I hate
parades I have a lot of gay friends
because it's required and my friend he
asked me for some advice he was gonna
come out to his 97 year old grandma
he's like mo are you out to your
grandparents I was like no man no one's
up to their grandparents I just waited
out I got a fun text from my friend in
the middle of the night
another friend I it was a photo of his
penis
ya see straight girls I'm just like you
I get the dick pics
he accidentally sent it to me he was
trying to send it to his girlfriend
Molly mo LLY my name is mo mo he is
lucky one more letter some people get it
you would have been sending a photo of
his poorly lit penis to M om which I'm
pretty sure spells mom yeah can you
imagine getting that text
oh it's Jeremy he didn't forget my
birthday after all my friend he was
begging me is like you have to delete
that photo off your phone I'm like well
kind of lesbian just keeps dick pics on
our phone but yeah like every time he
calls it shows up everybody welcome back
to the 24 hour mobile marathon what's
going on it's sponsored by Google Play
for the next 24 hours actually now I
think it's about how many hours gonna be
doing this for three there oh my god
we've all good for the next 21 hours
will be playing mobile games that's
until noon pacific time tomorrow we got
a lot of great guests coming up a lot of
great games coming up and right now
please welcome mo welch and iron Reaver
leave her leave her not rebirth that's
an enemy from Firefly hello moe hello
Eric come on in come on in we got a
green screen backer thanks for not
wearing green it's pretty good in now
now our background is like a knight's
head I'm kind of a some kind of a knight
because I thought because we're gonna
play this amazing game called lineage to
revolution which is gonna be fantastic
hopefully I've done never played it
before so yeah additional no oh I knew
we were gonna need to do this God we got
it download fast all right so what's
going well we're downloading files
what's happening guys how are you guys
we're good we're good I love it how did
you guys meet we met in Chicago ten
years on the old comedy circuit yes
pursue her crappy open
and you so you do it have you ever done
his show yeah I used to yeah we used to
produce it together oh my god oh oh you
cut him loose no no that's great and for
people who don't know Moe tell people
what you do think called Blair which is
available on TBS calm super funny all
this stuff you don't like is are you
guys big gamers big video game fans a
little bit I like road rage oh yes
that's it oh you're like that's it I
just named 19 games but that's it I'm
not well that's okay
can Christ is great lynnie chew I don't
know it either but we're gonna learn it
together okay this this is about
learning and about sharing and also
we're live right now I say hi to twitch
YouTube and Facebook
you got your twitch chat right there you
got your YouTube chat right there hey
coffee kills hey what's going on thanks
link to those shorts I forgot domain
already oh yeah maybe we can put a link
in the to Blair in the old chat aru's
and is that Conan's gum I watched it
begin this is Conan's gum yeah this is
do you want to take the conan to
challenge please say me to this gum and
as a joke I kind of don't want to
because it's disgusting
[Music]
it's on the ground it's also been on the
ground it's fine
oh my god mode taking one for the team
this is how we create excellent level
yes she did it oh that's a WoW it's good
yeah it's going back on the cap and
going back right over here mr. little
Samson don't think as the chat is a
little bit the chats a little bit
delayed so now we're just gonna see
everybody go oh all right well you know
what instead of playing ladies shoes
take
forever to download these files why
don't we while it's downloading play a
different game a little game I like to
call home escapes okay and I call it
home escapes because that's what it's
called that's the name of the game yeah
it's it's home and in home escapes how
are you guys with interior design
[Music]
[Laughter]
basically imagine that you're a sad
Butler okay and you've moved back home
in with your parents and I don't know
the circumstances really there's a dark
there's a dark backstory of this game
and you're gonna fix you need to fix up
the old house but to do that you have to
maybe match different jewels together in
a candy crush esque environment that's
ladies and gentlemen it's home yeah it's
that old number you know yeah Hollywood
just keep remaking the same movie it's
same things over and over that's it so
you know I will say I moved I lived in
New York for nine years and I moved
across the country to Los Angeles I only
brought like decorations for my house
and a bed that's all I brought like it
was crazy and it was so funny cuz as
soon as I moved in I it just fit like in
one corner of my apartment and I looked
around I was like why did I bring
furniture like I have a harpoon and I
have like all these like breaking things
and I didn't have like a green yeah
exactly a frame quilt made out of
t-shirts we've all done that because
when you can't you can't give up your
t-shirt yeah I'm a nautical themed
bathroom like you do and it's got a
picture of clams it's got a nautical
clock it's got a lot of it kind of looks
like a five-year-old lives with me but
I'm childless so it's really creepy
let's play some skates shall we so here
we go it's gonna be on the other tablet
just so you guys know so yeah I'm
guessing this game's gonna have some
pretty dope music who wants to take the
home escapes checkers
look at this sometimes when we dream
yeah
incredible he pulls it off I think this
is a movie are you controlling this here
we are see my child at home he's moving
back okay
he's smiling but look at the sadness in
those eyes you know exactly
it's such a heavy that I got here too
early well is by the way who lives in a
house this is horrifying a mess
huge though okay it is you know what it
has a lot of potentialities can't be no
way so much money Austin doesn't make
that kind of money that's true so I'm
not sure these are like gummies gummy
bears or I guess it's a Lampoon book
okay alright so yeah so Matt's the other
we go so match him up there okay yeah
perfect yeah see we need to do this like
in real life to get enough money to buy
some cool things you could do you want
to get crazy yeah do as many as possible
in a row then other things happen I
think there's like paper airplanes
instead of three minutes pretty nice
yeah it gets pretty bananas yeah if you
want to hit that plane thing I think
it'll fly around and this here plus some
stuff up yeah yeah alright swiping
yeah I can't wait for the home scapes
movie started like who's a cool bald guy
Gene Hackman who would be a cool gun who
would strat Harris this looks like it
this looks like a like a 18 year old
Gene Hackman I feel like pre French
Connection
oh very stanley tucci ask he's like yeah
you know we're just home escape you know
so what does that do see now we can buy
some nothing's as an exciting game like
replacing carpet this is way different
than the other game we're gonna I know
I'm trying to get the other game to work
actually read that makes you buy roof
before you buy carpet first I think it's
just cuz you tripped
no oh sorry dudes you're playing with
two errands I forgot exactly I'm gonna
get so when we get tired of home escapes
not that we will because home escapes is
amazing yeah if you're feeling down and
you you're not really if your parents
are kind of getting you down play this
game and your fake home ski parents can
make you feel good that's how they get
you with the Stars you know all you're
trying to do is just help out your
parents
[Music]
[Music]
you do have to think about like I feel
like there's some you know benefits to
playing these games like into pattern
recognition right yeah like exactly we
could probably test our IQ by playing
this game I think so I mean like you
know counting counting to four how many
bowties there are yeah I feel way
smarter already
yeah knowing are you guys when it comes
to home design are you guys minimalists
are you more hoarder I'm like right in
the middle like oh oh you mean well
adjusted and normal no not well the
thing is like awkward for a year
oh then I'll do that clean oh oh nice
do you let you do like a like a binge
and a purge is there a specific time how
do you know when it's time to get rid of
all your stuff when like I can't what
makes you go from like you had 83 yeah
and then you're like this one is the one
I need because I never do you know I got
some really cool so it's not to talk
about sweatpants everybody but if we
could just have a quick sweatpants combo
I got these really dope like sporty oh
yeah like the custom just gemma staring
at me I'm jogging them yeah like all
joggers yeah it's like European but so
here's the thing no sorry like I feel
are those appropriate for work because
they're really cool
I see here's my my thing is I need to be
a little uncomfortable at all times or
else I don't know just so like because
I've I'm too comfortable on sweatpants I
feel like I'm weirdly vulnerable you
know like if I come to work at
sweatpants I'm like I'm too comfortable
yeah I'm not I don't want people seen ya
know and not true actually my friend
works at complex yeah and he wears those
sweatpants one time either awesome like
really baggy shirts he's 42
really long like super like we're
talking like down to here yeah and then
just then from here down to here his
sweatpants right it's a mess it's a mess
yeah he makes all he does is make videos
about sneakers yeah and then he used to
Rick advice and he also wore sweatpants
there maybe I'm learning it's more about
him he's also not well respected right
he's fired from every job yeah
somebody's saying
hey Theo plaque says the puppies are
actually love me they'd barking because
I'm a predator first of all I've never
know one is intimidated by me ever about
anything especially not puppies but
puppy can take me down easily
I play to my ankle cuz I'm wearing
sweatpants and that takes me right down
you know do puppies like the got love so
I feel like puppies love everyone not to
say they're like oh I see so just know I
understand what don't puppies love Oh
getting spanks
no that's do people spank Punky's thank
apiece yeah I'm not going around
spanking puppies you went right to
spanking a hobby I'm just saying what
they don't like good
okay I mean you know what you're right
and I am wrong you know what me you
don't know what puppies are into maybe
some puppies like it so I'm just like
st. Bernard I've never eat a puppy I
need a hush puppy though cuz those are
darn delicious
it's just hush puppies maybe they just
couldn't fit hush on the shirt hush
puppies puppies that's right you you're
intimidated by me and you've never met
me that's just cuz you think I mean I do
have a large head I do think my head is
probably hmm like let's compare heads
how do you measure yeah but look I've
got like this much more head oh my god I
just says chaos I don't know you play
softball right I can't a softball team
basketball team oh you don't wear
helmets in basketball do ya you should I
should you know what I do think you're
an entertainer and a great entertainer
and I think most entertainers do have
big heads like you have a large head I
do
Conan says oh that's no exactly I do
have this theory that people who are on
TV or entertainers have larger heads for
some interesting fish that's how we got
big brains whoa see you guys this isn't
just a mobile game stream it's also
educational you're learning how to get a
big head that's right NBA NBA Jam big
head mode activated exactly that's me
that big what's going on what are you
doing over here we're gonna replace the
arm chair just letting that armchair
yeah
no doodad P no I don't have dogs I'm not
allowed to have pets in my apartment but
I do have a lot of crickets instead of
roaches a great piece
yeah when collecting no not
intentionally they just make their way
in like last night for instance so I had
to get a lot of sleep because we're
doing this 24 hour stream yeah so I was
like serious I went home last night I
was like you know you do that thing
where you're just supposed to look at
only yellow light like don't look did
all that stuff I had some high warm
liquid I said we're looking hot tea it
was it isn't warm liquid but it sounds
gross when I assume liquid liquid as a
word as a gross worker all agreed on
that and then I went to bed then I heard
a cricket went out and I found him he
was like underneath my router it was
like a long search for a cricket and
people I sometimes stream on my own
twitch channel people I've gone on
cricket hunts live cricket onto my thing
there's a giant cricket like this really
didn't start talking after you like made
a joke right no I could use the Jiminy
Cricket be brave because I make a lot of
poor decision the first time we're
cooking shows like staying up for 24
hours playing video games they keep the
bad spiders away how to stay safe
Australia except I live in Los Angeles
that's right there's a pro yeah I got
that big crickets are more interested in
these games good learn that's not gonna
work I think we gonna play it on here
okay there's not enough memory
when you guys get sick of this game we
could play a little lineage to
revolution oh I'm ready for that are you
ready for that
I'm actually not ready I want to get
this yeah let's get this arm chairs we
already got the arms okay this guy what
do you think makes this guy angry like
he's always happy what do you think he
gets upset about I'm like what was the
last time you yelled at somebody a bad
president all right fantastic wait can I
just see what happens when you match
five pieces yeah this is how they get
you man you give games are so addictive
they're amazing oh bomb power apart
let's just see what it does quick whoa
yeah let's make it alright sorry I'm
just gonna make another quick bomb
powerup sorry sorry it's real quick okay
yeah I'm gonna double tap boom this is
very satisfying alright no more no more
boss no more bomb
all right let's go full screen okay that
might take days
I hope so cuz I love renovating and as
long as it takes I that is my dream job
and if there's anybody out there needs
their place decorate yeah I'm having
sinuous schematic I used to have an
Egyptian room a nautical room and a
jungle room when I lived in New York I
actually was in the Village Voice
because of that I spent too much crap
yeah you can it's weird I also have a
giant picture of my face do you know a
girl like this you remember when Conan
gave me a haircut and shaved my head and
all that crazy stuff back in the day we
had a hair studio we were 30 rock a
hairy studio came in to the first floor
and so they asked for his my first start
on the show they asked for volunteers
from the staff for color to cut their
hair and I had no money so I was like
sure and so he like shaved off an
eyebrow and shaved this and put a
postage stamp like did all this crazy
stuff and dyed this orange and this
brown and then they printed out a before
photo that's nine feet tall of my face
like each eye is this big and that I
busted through it life right okay but
they printed too so I got to keep one so
in my house one whole wall is my giant
fat dumb face
still now still now horrified that's why
no one ever comes dude start thank you
start that oh yeah that's at least a
hundred dollar idea
now maybe not a million dollars are not
that expensive on eBay alright we're
gonna play a little lineage to
revolution this game is intense guys I
hope you're ready for it some intensity
because this game is gonna be this is
exist this is what alright so who wants
to play first all right you got a select
your race up there select your race okay
dark dark Oh dark Moses and yeah I love
a really long like the entire Lord of
the Rings trilogy even Bowie oh yes I
want one of these first walk around the
office
yeah yeah we're like look at a bass okay
oh my gosh oh yeah we yeah we got we
want to enter a cool name that don't
screw this up oh wow okay alright okay
Frederick's 675 this is a mobile game
mobile games are crazy powerful these
days they're awesome revolution yeah you
gotta get your tablet way no no yeah
kind of oh my god Wow yeah what is his
name I don't know the icon by the way
his him with his cab which is theirs oh
man I'm looking it up oh my god he's
doing calisthenics right now oh my god
he's changing weight switch back to the
other guy for a sec switch back to the
other thing look switch back to I keep
switching back to the other tablet look
at him do you look at me like he's doing
little calisthenics he's working out oh
my god this home escapes game you got a
little dizzy alright let's go back to
the lineage - sorry thanks oh my gosh yo
girl okay I thought she had horns and
long years so I was like what's going on
take some work to get familiar with the
area I usually just take a cooking class
you know what I moved to a new city I
don't need to take on work yeah yeah
I'll go to like you know I'll go to see
a comedy show or something dude a poor
plan lineage to revolution available on
Google Play it's pretty great I got all
this running we're doing cuz I'm way
better citizen awesome
yeah that's true you imagine Austin this
world I feel like you know
Austin doesn't go outside yeah this is
Austin's previous lifetime this is like
a past life regression hypnosis like I
was at Dark Elf places carpet haha look
at that dudes Arby's ripped
oh my god
gels he doesn't wanna like these dark
scars
yeah looking for some work a yeah
RPG land Frederick says awesome RPG line
quick switch back to the boring house
decorating game well he was doing
calisthenics
you know I think physical a physical
fitness is important it's good for the
mind good for the body
I know what's happening with this god
I'm ruining the game everyone no Blair
get rid of the Chad there's no how to
get rid of the chair
[Music]
every guy who looks like that talks like
you're right do it later dude add P
let's start of every fantasy RPG
slaughter you helpless animals that's
true it kind of looks like a buff jeremy
renner you know like a jeremy renner i
got a really had a really bad like
whittling accident
[Music]
what are all these scars you know i
don't know yeah this you should use some
neosporin like that yeah dude you don't
want to scar some coconut oil by the way
can't just see something you know
warriors like are all like they're all
scarred up and good that means you're a
terrible warrior
yeah you're getting scarred you're oh
you suck put some armor yeah look at
this guy's just wearing like a tank top
from that's a terrible fashion yeah wear
a tank top you gotta go belt man
everybody knows that that's a bunch of
bears now why are we just why are we
going around hitting bears with a stick
i would love to know how to take the
chaton
that's killing killing
so yeah oh yeah you know oh you know
what I got it I got know how to do this
what how did you get that thing you went
like this Oh
oh my god oh my god whoa this keep us
cut see it's amazing this game is dope
copy kills I mean it's no home escapes
oh no wait hit local get rid of the
local Douglass get away god you're
killing me alright you know I guess I
get along I guess I give up I guess I
give up I give up I don't know I give up
oh oh here we go Oh guys here we go
sorry I gotta get I gotta kill this chat
is that okay with everybody how do I do
this game device notices this is so
exciting everybody's all notification oh
here we go chat chat there we go oh no
it's still there great alright I give up
what's this oh my god alright I get how
do we okay no yeah I don't think you
give up yeah you accepted the quest yes
I can use a party chat yeah I guess
that's it Douglas I can't do it I keep
doing the same things alright if anyone
knows how to turn off the chat lady
revolution let me know you can make the
chat small fun take larger window
alright let's get out of the way and put
some Neosporin or something on your put
some ointment
salve or whatever our here we go learn
to a window Oh God this is what stuff in
here there we go got it all right we
made it smaller we did it all of us no
larger off yes look oh sorry fine sister
like local are we - its small small we
did it oh yeah
all right it's that's good enough that's
fine I just want to see more you know
yeah how does like I turn his head with
that kind of crazy armor he was like
what kind of army do what I don't know
but I like turtlenecks
give me something yeah give me something
with a bronze turtleneck I'm nervous for
us cuz it doesn't look like we have any
armor oh yeah we're basically wearing
like a Right Said Fred mesh shirt take
your rid of us over the game check
Frederick 675 we don't want to get rid
of you but the game chat is super
annoying
the chats game as much after she if
you're a gamer you know make this game
even cooler we can change the
decorations do you think we have
lightning powers or that's just the
static electricity building up from
running troop captain is gone he must
have gone for the port gate let's make
haste no it says let's make haste let's
go get him
I do like the auto questing in this
because I hate it when I don't know
where to go in a game it doesn't tell
you where to go this year a turret there
yeah we would not be this far yeah we're
killing we're getting there Shrek's
taser yes oh my god good lord
Wow turtleneck is not as helping us
[Music]
too sexy for armor that's true you know
what I think when you maybe wants to
show he's been working out a lot maybe
once you show up god no one in this
world wears armor the Shrek stone that I
basically have first thongs just say oh
the obituary god we look pretty good in
leather though I'm gonna put that out
there I mean not us personally I look
terrible in leather you don't want to
see this and like a form-fitting yeah
although you know what I would like a
leather cape yeah I think I want to
bring like a cape there are caves over
here maybe maybe sound a bust into it's
only oh my god it's only quarter to four
is it too early to bust into a cape
maybe it's not maybe I get the Cape hold
on you guys you gotta drink the Cape you
know oh you know what this is more of a
cloak this is a cloak or a cape I think
it's a cloak this is like kind of like
I'm in a cult yeah this is very good
this is very culty words very much Ling
East Hollywood on a Friday in my
neighborhood is this what you get that's
great oh your your lineage dub now
actually cut it you know what honestly I
figure they're gonna look really
intimidating but you just look like
you're in a Snuggie yeah we got this
little we can put this up yourself you
look really comfortable
oh my god five seconds and he's playing
Star Wars do you want to keep playing
you wanna keep playing stuff no it's
cool okay all right that was amazing wow
that's a your dress no just kinda like a
warrior I thought it was like a weird
everything his Aaron had no idea he was
playing store he was like does it uh I
guess it's Star Wars
oh this is really relaxing you're in a
Snuggie we're hearing some great music
you turtleneck is back captain Harold
we got Doug and Harold yeah this is a
fantasy game shouldn't be like Xander
with an X and like you know like like
Zanzibar zip Elizabeth mably or
something that sounds like a
thirteen-year-old trying to be in it
we're trying to buy beer oh yeah yes I
am captain Douglas no no that's not my
dad I'm captain Douglas look my ID in
the car no big deal it's just lineage to
Star Wars it looks like so oh you do
have a very Stevie Nicks Ian look 17
yeah everywhere click the backpack at
the top somebody said maybe that's the
click them maybe click the thing on the
left select items to sell
it's like that oh there you go sellable
you sell it up what are you selling
we're do we got a hundred Edina we just
pawned my guitar under a tricky is not a
joke that's true but being underage it's
pretty funny yeah that's my favorite
thing that's not a joke Wester party
dude we just quest we just quest it I do
request again continue questing
Frederick says she looks like a younger
more attractive female version of the
Emperor that then that's not the Emperor
that's like you just said like nine
things you look exactly the upper except
not at all like the emperor jean-claude
van Damme I don't know I guess this guy
kinda looks like jean-claude van yeah he
doesn't look like John Claude Van Damme
to me you know it looks like his who
plays um general Ross in the Avengers
movies who's that guy who one thing Who
am I thinking him under Harold
William Hurt that's it that's who he
looks very William Hart esque uh Sir
Robert stroll I'm not sure if this game
is PvP I think it I mean I think you can
join a clan but I don't know if it's if
it's other people or not you didn't
wanna upset her Frederick you didn't
know cetera it's okay just make out with
that bad who's this she's like I'm about
to go to the beach in my one of those
swimsuits
she looks over it yeah yes she's so like
whatever you know what all these Shrek's
are really on my nerves could you like
get rid of a movie goodness
she's barely wearing clothes she talks
like a bossy like fifth grader like I
need your help
I forgot my combinations the worst near
by monsters oh hi from Dubai hello Dubai
what time is it over in Dubai good lord
the pork is a Sith Lord so here's the
thing they put the pores in do you read
about this because they there are all
these birds on the island that they shot
so in the in the last Jedi
spoiler alert through they go to an
island and there's a lot of birds on the
island they made them into very slightly
different weird things called boards and
everybody's now saying that the porks
are like from the dark side or the the
Sith or something because that's the
other mood was on they were keeping you
in you you guys are nuts I know what
you're talking about
did you guys are you guys Star Wars fans
[Music]
their new Star Wars guy oh just the
video game that I whoa that's how you
get into Star Wars you're like yeah
this one time I played this game by
accident it was amazing spoiler alert at
last Jedi killed Sora's I gotta say I
love Adam driver was great
he was pretty good it's pretty pretty
dope he's a pretty like him Daisy deadly
is awesome that's right
Conan will be checking in once in a
while frequently uh-oh nothing ain't
nothing ain't party tab here takes I
think you just want to tap here except
ah I don't trust this you know what open
your mind Cordelia you know what it's
not just about appearances okay yes
she's good she trains trust these girls
that would be a great that'd be a great
twist
my name's to classic líneas new twist
we love Trek I don't know about Star
Trek versus Star Wars it's the age-old
question I think Star Trek is more about
science and exploration Star Wars is
more about like you know
yeah we're spiritual about a lot more
lightsabers and Star Wars wavers not a
lot of lightsabers and start I don't
know if there are any actually yeah
let's make haste to my colleagues
hey Katsura Jin good to see you lineage
is to linear well played well played
so Star Wars is more of a space fantasy
that's true
whereas Star Trek is more hard sci-fi
suite of the suite people have changed
their minds about the last chat about in
a few years I don't know will they I
guess only time will tell what what the
last Jedi has done two Star Wars is
legacy I can't believe I'm talking about
this I can't believe it it's amazing
yeah honey are they good or bad
thank you yeah this isn't the right
music for an enemy that's not how you
hold a sword by the way I just want to
keep it away from your neck you know
tell us why he's got that scar though
yeah yeah maybe you should keep all
knives below the waist there buddy just
a little tip from me to you wait Oh
Jimmy B wants to know do you guys like
Star Wars or Star Trek Star Wars style
or are you guys you guys even care about
either I don't I
I haven't gotten into them yet all right
more defenders phantom planet
oh yeah that's pretty job and a great
mass the third option usually yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're not a Captain
Planet was he made up of other of
children like they all came together and
then yeah like kind of like a human
Voltron almost no are they summoned
Captain Planet yeah
when our powers when their powers unite
and they are Captain Planet they are
captain I think they are savage okay
which will captain play this is a kind
of way
seven planets not even Captain Planet
he's nothing he's named Leo I don't know
he's a Halloweeny he kind of sounds
genie ask guys with Captain Planet real
or not who is Captain Planet what is he
doing here why is he only a captain
environmental castle he's like Casper
just want about I'm sure probably both
but just don't I don't
he was as real as you or I he's still
the real to me Captain Planet is real so
wait did he he was then summoned from
another dimension he's sounding a lot
like a genie honest yeah well when they
fuse that's kind of gross all the kids
fused together and then Captain Planet
and then maybe Captain Planet heard like
five different voices and he was just
tortured like you know like get a crazy
multiple personality disorder
oh yeah ring ghost there we go
he's maybe some sort of Gestalt organism
what is gestalt me
he's summoner protect the earth from
pollution guys we can do that ourselves
we don't need let's not put it off on a
Captain Planet you know all of it I hate
to say it but all this all sounds like a
tent-like 13-year old doing voices oh
yeah yes all the guy all the all the
characters this game are just like kids
on top of other show there is something
this is my note from my parents
Darkwing Duck is cool toxic avenger
great oh yeah
this girl's back trying to help hell
yeah okay so Moe how did you get
involved to come in the very beginning
what what made you sign up for everybody
out there who wants to do comedy it's
too scared because of these Shrek's what
made you do it would I think like most
of the time you see something and you
say like I can do that later a lot of
comics I hear they're like oh I can do
that
and I guys watching I was actually
watching SNL and I was like how do you
do that like I think maybe I could do
that right yeah and then the next year
[Laughter]
two months later I was hi I'm Lorne
Michaels I don't think so I will say
from everyone I've talked to you on my
experience like comedians when you're
starting out are very supportive because
they know how bad it is you know like so
people want to see comedians want to see
other people get into comedy which is
very cool yeah like an improv class like
it's a very supportive environment there
are no mistakes right yeah exactly it's
all about the yes adapting in the ending
it was horrible and I had to stop
everyone was really mean to me well
though I think there's a lot of kinds of
comedy out there and just like some
people aren't great performers they
might be great writers yeah and you but
you find out by leaving me yeah are you
talking about amazing that's dress
person on the couch but yeah I think
it's all about doing Erin how did you
get Nogami I was writing I was ready
there we go see and then I was working
at the Cheesecake Factory yeah I know I
was working there than like four other
people I knew we're comics there I feel
like you probably got a lot of material
bones what sir and can you give us an
example of something that happened that
you were just like oh my god this has to
to put this in script or something let's
see one time this woman she's like I
need stuff that's from the earth Oh
Eileen meteorites right it's true then
you don't eat food if you you could you
know what they should make I'm still
waiting for a menu that's made out of
like fruit leathers I don't know edible
menu man okay you decide alysha's yeah
there's like stamp into it just like
real leather you can make a belt out of
it you know there's a lot of things you
can do with fruit leather exactly I mean
probably use it as armor in lineage to
revolution right to bring it back home I
only kind of like alien meat I would eat
the meat of an alien I would do it would
you yeah I need probably anything I mean
I have II pretty light like how would
you want it though in sauces oh that's a
good stack of great question I mean I
feel like an it might be I'm guessing
it's gonna be kind of string it looks
gamey yeah looks pretty gamey
I'm imagining like some kind of like
like a crocodile or yeah yeah probably
definitely has an octopus taste yeah
yes and then yeah maybe but it's like
maybe scales like here's what I like I
like a lot of like a lot of a lot of
business to do with your meat you know
like with a crab I like cracking it open
and doing the thing and you get the
butter and there's a tiny fork instead
of a regular four I like a lot of
accessories I like the process
naturally eating's just kind of boring
but I like you know home you know you
put it on a thing and then you twist it
around and I'm not just talking about
plain touch to dragons but you know what
I'm saying I like business to do with my
meat okay ice is just like oh we eat if
you eat what you want
alien like PA Chang stuff all right
what's that one yeah oh yeah oh yeah
yeah what's it kind of like I want like
a grill in front of me or like one of
those little creme brulee flamethrowers
you're ready to go with your husband I
want to pick it out of it
yeah but aquarium Red Lobster well guys
is four o'clock that's a good time I
think to check in with Conan before we
do
say goodbye to Aaron Weaver and Moe well
please check out Moe's digital series on
CBS comm called Blair that Aaron wrote a
bunch of and you can also follow me on
twitter at momo welch and instagram olj
go to mo else calm and Aaron is a great
show at the improv you live in Los
Angeles come see it what's a call
comedians used to know Thursday nights
comedians you should know on Thursday
nights at The Improv thank you guys for
joining us
all right let's check in with well it's
four o'clock I'm not gonna lie to you on
days that we tape this is usually the
time when I'm done with everything I
have to do before the show and I get a
little bit of time like 20 minutes to
myself and that's when I go in my
dressing room this is true and I shut
the door and I turn off the lights and I
close my eyes and I just lie on this
couch for 20 minutes and try and just
think about what's become of my life and
then there's a banging on the door
exactly 20 minutes later and it's David
hoppin and he comes in with a green tea
for me green tea is an antioxidant tea
kids you should check it out
and then hey and no more vaping guys
it's not a good idea and then I drink
the green tea so it's safe--for o'clock
so special time to me that's what I
usually feeling pretty relaxed trying
come down a little bit and get to his
end space before I go out there and make
that show that America seems to demand
well anyway four o'clock I'll see you
later yeah welcome back everybody how's
it going thank you again to Aaron Weaver
in mow well for stopping by they were
fantastic I think we learned a lot about
alien meat the kind of armor you should
wear and home decorating so that's just
what you're gonna get our 24-hour mobile
marathon stream sponsored of course by
Google Play coming up later on we have
even more surprise guest exclusive music
performances behind the scenes goodies
snacks coffee all sorts of good stuff
maybe someone will take a nap on camera
who knows that's the kind of exciting
stuff you're gonna see in the next 24
hours right now we are very very excited
to welcome two people who you know from
the regular appearances on our show
because there are writers
Shaner guys getting there guys oh my god
you guys are very snappily dressed
here's now this looks great this is
great all right I'm gonna turn over you
guys are gonna play a little game on
enigma here's our chats a little chat
you got twitch and YouTube there and we
got Facebook as well here's this and all
right away I'm just giving this chapter
finger all right okay so we'll just do
this to get into I've never played this
before I have no idea how okay should we
start with new game
is that the best way to go all right you
know what let's just be honest you're
you're gonna know what you're doing with
more than
now I hope that this music is great book
speaking of text worthy oh yeah it's
boring yes yay somebody thinks I look
like Dan Harmon thank you
the people on YouTube are way nicer than
the people into it just to see you guys
now yeah
they are writers they deserve no respect
twitch people you need to get nicer
we're gonna stop looking at your feed
eat [ __ ] alright follow the tutorial
next so what is this alright so you we
can't figure out how to make the hand
move right guys we're done we're already
out I'm not playing anymore cuz I can't
touch anything did someone tell us watch
oh there is oh okay okay oh there you go
fire extinguisher it might be handy so
you touch the objects oh I thought they
made it look like that you were supposed
to got it move the actual okay I want
the fur okay so you want to use the fire
things to put out the fire yes man and
their sisters lady touched the fire and
exciting world up to my earth out but it
still big trouble okay so now you have
the toolbox I'm not a knife don't get
too excited it's just a screwdriver I
prefer the cocktail screwdriver height
but move the hand around hey Tony just
build a dome over it Hey
lovely chemistry screw you Jimmy B don't
care so I'm the hitting this screwdriver
not gonna work oh so he's kind of giving
us clues that doesn't make any sense
[Music]
tap anywhere to continue all right let's
see what this thing is all her shoot
that's enough you wanna parachute right
okay so now agreed exit so poke the exit
all right the doors champ oh that's why
I have a plate with screwdriver here we
go you have a parachute what happened
use parachute I thought you were wearing
yeah there we go all right okay we've
made some progress here okay it's all
about knowing what to poke I'll read
some of the comments from these monsters
well there's a cow she's really pretty I
have to say I like the animation stuff
good touch to the calf all right well
that was it with the cow hope you
enjoyed that letter I think there's a
guy there oh look there's that wrench
he's trying to fix his car it's a decent
wrench yeah no he's poor oh is that a
Nazi
I thought maybe who is that it's me
Helga your wife
can you Pastor Holly I'm doing an
impression of his wife passing the
wrench
all right so then I kept the objects now
get the hang of this okay cool thanks
here are the car keys listen
do not start it while I'm in here we'll
see about that is the guy on the right
Greek end god x2 crack configuration of
the switches I think we okay I think we
just have to figure out which
combination of switches to turn off Oh
see it was just all right let's grab the
key we are Nazi Germany I'm ton what is
your job title / what does it entail
date today we are staff writers on the
show day to day we do a lot of talking
and thinking and writing both in teams
and in pairs sometimes sometimes alone
often alone yeah
yeah all right so we have to go back
this way oh oh it's on the side of the
okay so pay more attention to our visual
surroundings yeah I know what we're
gonna do we're gonna dig a hole put the
leaves over the hole yes this is how
they defeated the Nazis they dug up a
lot of hole all over Europe and they
just kept falling in the hole exactly
[Music]
have we been to Conan's house yeah yeah
I really have put out a knife it's
really nice
oh wait he's pretty rich it turns out
he's pretty wealthy so what was the
thing on the night they said they
wouldn't let me do anything with it
basically it said that the holes not
deadly enough that's why I think you put
my pockets you can't fit it so what if
you
[Music]
that's what she said can't you get
inside the hole that's what she said can
you
where does your penis go need something
to make it did look alright nice alright
so I'm gonna take a comment when they
don't not cruel and about me being
Jewish probably what's your favorite SNL
character someone asked that that was on
YouTube it was Ian Murphy the in Murphy
of all time it was open-ended what's
your favorite Jackie Rogers Jr if it's
the whole time well that one sketch the
hundred thousand dollar jackpot what
yeah
what's my alternative medicine that's an
SC TV character that he did for one
season oh yeah one frozen caveman Laura
keep it as a good character there Tony
I started doing comedy in New York City
in 1997 the thing I'm most proud of
[Music]
what's the thing you're most proud of
writing I think one of the wall burgers
bits for meat maybe I think what the
thing is I'm most proud of I'm very
proud of soup to nuts but I'm only gonna
be saw it
[Music]
Wiki barren stuff those are all right
minty created minty to indicate cover
the whole with knives but I only have
one knife here
let's do this okay I think we missed I
think we might have missed something
that we were supposed to take really
wrong is there like a hole okay what
about that branch is that something you
can grab the branch looks like it's see
the branch on the tree that's we know
covered with leaves no here we go again
touch the branch again see what it says
the one the rest is like I line with you
like even with your heart idea how to
use a bit nerdy aha
Thank You Andre somebody mrs. wiki beer
knife on branch
I think Frederick 675 has got the right
idea but how do I do that
juice that's it and now if it's the
branches oh I can't okay so they just
need to be not blocking there we go see
now it's branch in the hole but branch
is not necessarily deadly yeah lucky
sharp in the branch with the unite all
right now it's teaching us how to use
it's a pretty cool teaching us how to
use tools so you can use objects on each
other to create the okay maybe some
gravel get a nasty column notice us okay
okay we will notice you may that's
moving I'm proud of that one too I wrote
that yeah yeah
do I like hot hand time not really what
is it that's anime porn yeah
[Music]
teaching skills have somebody likes my
pets
Madeleine Sydney Thank You Madeleine
yeah Muhsin thumbs were the best where's
your favorite vinyl record aways Joy
Division's substa Pearl Jam's Vitalogy
no he's not laid-back but he's very
funny in Iceland did you run your
podcast segment by Pardo before n-no he
had no idea what I was going to do and
he never does that's how I like to do it
okay oh this guy alex is doing his first
stand-up set next week
good luck outlook Alex you should do
some of these jokes from the feed how
can I get a job like you guys Congress
do comedy for 10 to 15 years and then
eventually a friend will get give you a
job yes you may end up working on a
bunch of other little things first
Yeah right like webseries you me and
working on I mean at that point maybe
that's all there will be but but yeah it
may not happen right away but you have
to invest time what's your favorite
video game Skyrim this is from Troy
lightning on YouTube played so much
Skyrim mine is red day to redemption
that's great can we put the sequel to
that hey rod is here Alex Rodriguez oh
that's great yeah yeah he was a great
player for a really long time well
thanks for tuning in I mean it's really
it's weird I don't know that you use
values your time but but thanks for
several Oh which city is better to get
started in New York or Chicago that's a
really good question I think either one
you're fine I think I think either one's
great but I think you'll end up in New
York and you probably won't end up in
Chicago right you know but if you start
in Chicago a place to start you never
get good at comedy in Chicago yeah
and then eventually drop might pull you
to
Krillin this person Raging Bull 34 on
Twitch hissing Red Dead Redemption
equals best ps3 game ever I agree 100% I
played it on the Xbox 360 or old xbox
what I have played on xbox 360 Layton's
favorite game - do we ever get to meet
celebs yes all the time
no every now and again sometimes we'll
get to shoot things if I make out i met
the rock last week yeah that's cool that
was movie is a syllabic a joke has been
done before constantly always worry
about that yeah like me who control
Twitter to see if something's been done
we always like check herself against it
it can be really frustrating so onion
thing well yeah cancel the whole bit
because onion yeah we had I I had a
sketch that I was working on that had
written the script I gotten all the
casting we were just about to shoot in
that afternoon like literally just about
to shoot we had this it all set up and
cameras and then one of the writers
found in Instagram focuses by the onion
that had the same premise as the sketch
I was gonna do they just posted it like
two minutes before that no we just call
the whole thing off that's called
integrity there is integrity a lot of
people would not do them okay just keep
you guys like tritrippy I've always
thought that'll be fun to try to create
a world for a video game now you go
probably
pokegaard to get his attention with what
you see what happens if you just keep
going I won't be able to know he I can't
go any further
hmmmm so have to go back here and I have
to find some way to get him to fall into
that hole I think to get his attention
what if I climbed up here can you get up
there and get the OU the cap the
questions come to fast and furious day
oh the Bell Bell on the count all right
nice job so I'll I'll do a little
ding-a-ling-a-ling uh the ding-a-ling
strategy well looks like there's other
stuff in the tank everything you might
have to go back eventually to stem to
take that little circle appeared three
times like along three of your little
panels is he just gonna shoot me if I do
this much like in real world war two he
will hear the bell become curious and
then walk blindly can I hang the bell on
this the music makes me feel like I'm
really committing a heist well someone
just tell us how to play this game
ring the cows bell for help yeah we're
trying to figure out a way to use new
bell I don't need help
milk the cows Conan's forehead is like a
desert where nothing grows
yes thanks Marcus I was really feeling
about yourself right now Marcus foxy
pink girl thinks the music in this game
is cool yeah
in in wild we did first so he's asking
me a bunch ruck when I act on the show
no actually I never am I receive a medal
for my last bowel movement yes we oh no
we have a cover the whole yeah oh that's
what you doing babe sorry yes you're
right thank you whoever who is that we
said that Sabrina Sanders thank you
you're very wise Sabrina sighs forgot
that stuff all right
what do I do next
wait let's find a better sputtering
about yeah let's go be hung on the whole
yes
ring the bell here we go folks big
action sequence oh [ __ ]
check it out big so yeah budget on this
one my gosh what could happen come
closer
he could shoot you from there but no
he's gonna walk he just disappeared like
a like a little fairy that's it that was
the effect of him falling into the hole
this war is hell I thought we were gonna
see like it impaled not Caesar oh
there's something find the ladder do I
want to take this thing it's missing one
of the wheels I would say that if I
played this game at home I would turn
this music off me
oh there's another Nazi and probably
don't want to be can I just stab him
give it a shot
is he asleep life
I gotta feel like this game is not gonna
be the kind of game around standing okay
oh you're gonna smoke them out by
blocking the chimney but how do we block
the chimney Oh flag can I take this bike
hey is this game bad I wouldn't call it
bad necessarily as it is the very the
wrong game for us either yeah like if
you were on us right now playing this
might be having a good time lag worked
the thing said no point blog continues
now here's another way to get into the
house right we got a okay lock the front
door the [ __ ] you mean yes oh you have a
key did this at the key - no that's what
I do
yeah I need out the keys we okay so now
we do this you have to find the village
troll and pay the troll that sounds like
a Black Sabbath song where's Cole right
so what can I use this key here that's
now locked there we go I wish I was only
one century saloon on it is that they
said you look like that yeah I'll take
that
here we go
now what happens
I'm gonna see like smoke coming out of
that or did I just kill him did you just
let us fix the edit not see with smoke I
think I might have can we just watch him
suffocate
ah there it is kind of creepy yeah
we are murdering Nazis so cute though
they're just disappearing a little puff
balls of smoke it's such a cute way to
do it it's which none but the bulb is
missing yeah
Baroness 94 has the right idea removed
the freakin music yeah that is driving
me crazy
how do we do that try hit the pause
button and there's a little menu there
I'm guessing no sorry
screw it you're stuck with some music
yeah my where's Carly where's Carly
where's Carly where's Carly where's
Carly where's kind of my skirt poof is a
terrible way to get got that is true
frederik 675 on twitch our dude looks
like the Mythbusters guy Oh our parent
who looks like one of the guys from now
oh yeah he's a big mustache yeah he does
all Nazis but not show swastikas what
here's the mother ignore negative
comments from Joe our notes no swearing
iPhones are dropping
sorry for swearing alright we've been
pointing out there- coming yeah and
swear yes I get to do like a doing don't
list them yeah
there are many there guidelines for
Sivan we're not following any of them
let's see how long have you worked at
Conan I've worked here almost ten ten
years I've worked on all every now every
version of the show from week might to
the prison yes yes I saw of you you
started like just a couple weeks after
me yes we start right around the same
time though how did you get your job
pretty much the same way we both did a
lot of stand-up in New York City and for
a long time and eventually you just
decide like yeah we both we both got
agents and your agency they when you get
an agent they ask you what you want and
then you they'll say like you don't to
write and do one already for sitcom and
you want to do this yeah and then you
kind of make a plan of action
you know I know in my case and I just
said I want to submit to like late-night
shows and sketch shows and stuff and
when things came up they let me know
about it yes and then you just do the
work and also from just being part of
there's a stand-up scene for so long I
think by the time we got hired there
most of the writers on the staff already
knew us from doing shows with us and
stuff exactly do you know sugar mean yes
we do
that's Andrew Weinberg oh yeah he's a
very funny right yeah super funny writer
he co-created the show Eagleheart
where is Conan you know he's a busy guy
yeah diet flannel what is your name my
name is Andre do Bouchet right from the
show you saved words s what is your name
where is your real name age sex location
what is it really somebody is asking
about no I'm asking you said oh yes we
still talked to Brian
Madeline IMS on Twitch do we keep in
touch with my sec yes yeah
he's one little do greatest people ever
yeah I miss him me too Sebastian how
hard is it to keep from kissing each
other right now he's not not hearty no
yeah it's a little hard for me my
attention my tattoo says fourth now in a
fear no darkness which is a Lord of the
Rings quote yes Isis he likes us Thank
You Gerson Monroy that's all we that's
the only reason we're here thank you it
look like Borat Thanks alright we just
we address a lot of those pertinent
questions not to trying to get out a
door and it's performing a series of my
Newton tasks so keep going home in a
linear manner wait we can't go any
further
oh we got we've got to fix the bike with
what was there a wheel house take a gun
oh that's a bicycle pump yeah
for some reason it's on top all right
place okay there we go
[Music]
okay that doesn't
oh we need a wheels find a missing wheel
first book that was not really a swear
technically yes true right now is there
I mean we can't go any further right
it's not letting us go any further there
was there wheels on the tank there's a
possibility that maybe we can take one
of the tank news
[Music]
wherever there's like a little I thought
there were like little panels on it is
Tony the cameraman mm-hmm mrs. mr.
Potato Head ass James Francis wants to
know can he make your comment and then
stab basil yes we just saw that one I'm
sorry you're so sad
send another comment James Frain system
if it's where's Conan I don't know go
stabby stabby all right we gotta stab
this tire no why would I think that we
were just listening to it we can't break
a tire to go using somewhere else hey
guys how do we find a bicycle tire
somebody have a like genuine advice
about that butterscotch yes I played
that butterscotch the clown and he wrote
those bits there you go
synergy that is synergy could someone
just and your comments post the wiki
walkthrough of this game go to the bike
shop there's no bike shop wait
can't I just hint just google it whoa
what just happened what is happy never
shil it's a commercial oh is it you get
a hint like if I want to hit you
the game no one wants to play
take one off the back
[Music]
someone's a bit of all the old wow
that's way back okay wait what happened
get out of here get back in the game so
you're talking characters then I will be
happy instead of asking questions that's
for you where this guy on twitch is
asking the Tolkien character oh man it's
got to be Gandalf I don't think there's
any contest there Gandalf is the best
why can't why can't just take a tire on
this is jordyn really that weird in real
life weirder yes
Jordan is he's weird interesting
character I don't totally understand
the thing about Jordan that and this is
I don't mean to talk out of school about
Jordan but the thing that always
perplexes me is about Jordan is that
he's so rigid he comes across so rigid
and so kind of clean and put together
but then his personal space is an
absolute disaster his office is a mess I
think you've watched the show enough
you've seen if you've ever seen you have
you've ever seen his office on any of
the remote character clan entry about
the guard tower thank you sir
[Music]
look what that weekend I just went up a
tree now there's a hedgehog or has been
arrested for eeeh terms tomatoes because
her new tomatoes in the general head he
knows now he's sick and the boar is
awaiting military court
well we gotta free that board make sure
that's the key we have he's in the house
waiting for some medicine go talk to him
you know do we just kill him
accidentally no okay I know this weed
you secure farm animals decision I'll
bet it is
[Music]
random weed couldn't we just go take all
the weeds anything that's called weed
couldn't we just go here the the guy had
too many damn those big beans oh he's
got flatulence I have the medicine
already healing herb bicycle pump give
him more flatulence hey I'm confused
is is this particular general on our
side so why we're not worried about ya
[Music]
I don't yeah he's a good guy really her
boom oh yeah it's called double-double
tones over sippy cup where's the
magazine oh there's a light bulb where
the purple thing will just take he says
I can't because he's sleeping oh okay
asking for I don't think it has doors
are locked
[Music]
I'm leaving this one while I walk my dog
you're welcome
thank you I'm already married sorry
use the mirror in the Sunbeam to set
fire to the flag
watch this innovative where's the same
so sure a scheme even enough credit this
games crazy
oh oh and the Sunbeam look how do I move
it well what's the point of wanting to
burn that flag you know wake him up we
can wake him up with this the record
player there's no record it's all about
finding objects to stick in other
objects that's what she said yay forever
just freeze and that's how we die
alright let's see let's take some more
questions while we
suffocate him with a pillow thank you
these people are thank you fish steak
monsters I can't do it
side button on tablet to turn off the
music people are not just being there
alright no more music
enjoy hey guys I'm sorry I turned off
the music thanks for playing I can't I
don't know how to stop it
Oh del taco bit
oh that was me and dan cronin another
writer here oh the infinity that was
great yeah that was that's one of my
favorite things I just I didn't want to
say it because it's about pooping it
feels bad to say that's one of your
favorite things but that was really fun
to do let's see somebody off a raft kill
marry or have coitus with Conan Jordan
Andy hmm any of them or have sex with
any of them coldest best yeah I played
that guy too
yeah but some of these are rude who's
the rest of us we just seek require
going oh did you guys write the skit
with the intern and the gigolos mug that
wasn't really a skit that was like a a
remote did that was based on a plate
yeah we'll switch ups terrible play
something else yeah Brooke this is too
hard we're we're dum-dums we're a couple
of dum-dums oceanhorn and you can start
this one all right okay we're playing a
game called ocean one right now is it
about a narwhal monster of Uncharted
Seas bullets do you feel pressure when
you resent a new bit yes rehearsals are
really uh rehearsals are very stressful
sometimes yeah they feel a little bit
like an audition
rather than like we know our rehearsals
are weird cuz we sometimes go to
rehearsal with more stuff than we're
gonna have in the show mm-hmm
so then things get weeded out after
rehearsal so that it can be a little bit
stressful because you don't know if
something's gonna work or not let's see
what's the best way to get in a creative
state you want to know this is my answer
the best way to get Nakuru of state is
to go walking by yourself or go running
I just think you should move to
California oh that's fun right yeah if I
don't want three upstairs and there's an
answer right yeah
when will a guy come back look at that
hopefully next month I guess like when
when after the Italy show airs then he
will press the school argue that you
should have gone to below the grandstand
someone just asked how many shirt
changes bleh is going to do and then 124
we're gonna say you have a number to
beat
I'm gonna say yes he probably is doing
24 and then he probably planned to do 24
and he's nodding which means it's
admiration you hired the the car that
doesn't shares concerts right Lady Gaga
Lady Gaga's a billionaire
what if The Witcher guy just got up and
he was naked in there when he's coming
someone asks when's Kony that's this fun
new twist on where's Conan's wins comes
yeah someone on YouTube asks 11 p.m. he
gets correcting himself a bit magic
wears currency favorite movie someone's
asking someone named classic gamers on
youtube to ask me what our favorite
movie is - sideways this is about two
guys travelling a wine country
[Music]
yeah that's our favorite recent movies
John wick which is my favorite movies
get out I thought was amazing yeah
that's awesome
I'm a huge fan of all the Marvel movies
I thought Black Panther was great and I
actually thought the most recent
spider-man was really great yeah how
much are we getting paid for this like
kind of an insane amount of money I feel
weird saying that we're getting paid
nothing clean nothing we're getting paid
nothing what happened to vici bear we
stopped doing wiki bear because the
person who I wrote them with and did the
voice at wiki bear does no longer
working here he he passed yeah I didn't
want to do with anybody else
Bryan Bryan stack was he's integral yeah
I felt like he was wiki bear Alex Guzman
it gets it on John wick hey guys what
are your favorite movies uh huh I just
asked the question
I just blew their minds wait where's
Conan is not a movie mm-hmm where's
Conan - slide your finger - move oh here
we go John wick lol that plot was
terrible what's terrible about a plot
where they kill a dog and then he kills
everybody else that's fantastic that's
lead it's simple
that soon
there's the fact is they're just so I'm
just getting coins when I'm leaving Paul
I wish him all the best
someone said they like the crow it's a
cool movie they're remaking the crow
with Jason Momoa someone said they like
the one is that the Jet Li movie the one
I think you're wrong you stirred little
Sam
[Music]
but at least his music's better oh
that's nice thank you fish dicks 30
alright does this thing hurt me let's
see looks like it
[Music]
where are you cactus do you write jokes
for other shows other than Coney
[Music]
there's no reason to someone singing I
want to cruelly make someone said the
thing by John Carpenter's off you guys
are it's a green arrayed movie that
movie get read it so many nightmares on
the carny how do you do any of the
things how do you do stuff as I'm
standing there fever
they're asking if Mark Marin is our
favorite character on the show that's
very funny
Clark merits room six he is a character
that is very funny
what do you think I should be doing here
folks
[Music]
yes the nightclub scene in John wick was
a one I'm not sure what that means but
yes I'll bet that means something good
so that agree it's not as good as the
nightclub scene that starts the first
blade movie no is it yeah the first one
that the dance club yeah yeah yeah I
tried it's a dance club yeah I don't
know any ideas here can you tell us a
dad
hit the plants with your stick that's
assumed sang at the plants yeah do you
do that maybe the plants do something
[Music]
favorite fast food restaurant someone's
asking these are all great questions um
really cutting to the core fast-food
restaurant you like del Taco right
I love Del Taco but I think is that my
favorite fast-food
I think it's loose it's local but his
wings stop fast food yep okay when you
stature that's great I live very close
to a McDonald's my favorite like what
can you do other than just whack things
with a stick okay let me figure out how
to jump can you do are you allowed to
jump if you stay behind the tree and
keep making a guitar with the action
button with action buddy
there's no actually the circles of
triangles
[Music]
alright and do what we can then what
[Music]
you must place all the pots on the grave
to honor your honor your for various
Mexican the deceased elders pots don't
have enough grape sauce in them I have
the grave sauce I found some grave sauce
sending it
what oh I threw the jar and it gave me a
heart you know I'm just like in real
life
[Music]
Kermit's hot let's go see Herman
maybe he has more grave sauce did you
sleep well this gruff one on the right
who's your favorite philosopher that
guy's a real I liked Spinoza this is my
favorite Zelda game yeah this is very
Zelda
by sedition I do stand-up from time to
time the nose I what is that a jukebox
it's a checkpoint and just hitting the
technical music hey guys I feel like I
like to name about four-year-old would
have completed the first six levels by
now because they would intuitively know
what they're supposed to do collectively
mints oh go down the ladder there you go
oh there's a treasure up there I can't
have it who are we underground now every
case thank goodness okay we went
underground
and we're using a stick to beat up a
cactus gave us dude we just cost the
show a lot of money here in my king
I have sticks and a plant there's a
thing with life spikes and I'll hit it
so hard in case you have 15 years I'm
gonna keep doing can I have this you
just use the fall season's budget I love
this what's in the chest I feel like
this is so infuriating for anybody who's
watched they wouldn't they would have
gotten like a million gemstones it and
iris through or through magic office
we've got a crystal through a bottle of
magic off into the ocean take that magic
well you made the ocean magical I don't
think it's gonna let you knock the chest
into the sea how do I get over it
what's that thing down there we can
angry beetle see can I go into the water
or die oh it's the pusher crab I will
die the crab has the Punisher symbol on
it that is the Punisher he was turned
into a crab by an evil wizard this game
is weird now you're back story now he
wanders the beach
killing throw your stationery knobs you
keep pressing the action button your
target move I don't understand
throw a lot of it well that much you've
completed okay so I have to hold on to
it all right you know what does that get
you if you throw you throw the pot at
the crab my guess is the crabs gonna
hurt you crab I hit him there you go and
he turned into a gym I killed him anyway
Joe abandoned me with the jar driver an
achievement floating crystals that
should not be achieved so I feel the
Curb Your Enthusiasm
Seinfeld I think curvier Newseum is
hilarious but Seinfeld is just is
classic and just sillier
favorite superheroes the Incredible Hulk
hands down I'm actually gonna get it
hooked alright we're gonna approach this
methodically
where's Conan now we're gonna accomplish
a lot watch how many writers do you need
for a sketch on Conan show this is on
YouTube this is from meow 1 I would say
one minimum sometimes two sometimes more
sometimes there will be an idea that
gets presented to all the writers when
we're meeting and then everybody kind of
kicks in jokes and stuff yeah first new
presenting it will go back and write it
so just I you're gonna say I appreciate
how the water is kind of coming in and
receiving that's neat that's kind of
calming to watch it's nice here it's
cereal I don't really was cereal anymore
we used to be my favorite thing in the
whole world now I don't eat it anymore
yeah we can swim let's go okay so you
drip you drown if you go too far into
the water I thought we were swimming we
were just submerged
jerk Kona by Everclear in the Bourbon
who is a better body these are crazy
these are cuckoo questions guys I can't
answer that's a personal program on a
body you like Randall Brown on YouTube
asked can I be a writer on Conan sure
Magus yeah sure no problem Randall
paperwork yeah
just con come on by I feel like you
should be able to climb up have you ever
regretted something that you've done on
the show I have no I would say that one
thing that I didn't show that I mean
there's lots of stuff that doesn't go as
well as you'd like but but do you have
you ever done a thing on the show that
you're like I wish I hadn't even done
that that God on the show probably I
just can't remember
they've been there's one thing I deal
like I'm dying and oh okay I felt like
bummed out everybody and it was a great
before we broke for the holidays one
year it's like the day of our holiday
party and it was a sketch about a
company that makes edible Pig anuses oh
they sell them to feel like you're an
actor they such a it was such a bummer
I'd liked the idea but it was just such
a bummer of a sketch do you think every
comedian is a comedy nerd no but a lot
are I would say I think like most
comedians I know like wantnt would talk
about comedy all the time maybe just
talk about all day I think oh yeah
what are some podcasts you're listening
to this is from remove Sagat from San
Francisco script notes this is good
good podcast about screenwriting I
listening I'm listening to thing called
embedded that's an NPR podcast about one
thing anymore
finally push this wait I'm actually
starting to quasi understands what I'm
doing over here
oh so someone's saying I'm gonna have to
write on YouTube because we're not
paying attention to the Twitter comments
okay sorry buddy sorry twitch whoever
that is you Boris oral Boris 13 oh the
genesis of the animosity between Andy
and Tony is that it was completely
arbitrary and there's no reason
whatsoever I just thought it would be
funny if Tony hated Andy for no reason
whoo I got a regular key well I work for
a regular Oh someone's who must have
just jumped into someone named software
dev what a cool name software dev what
is your role on the Conan show we are
both sketch writers software dev you
seem like a real human being my my name
is alpha product quality assurance wants
to know right well I got a regular key
that must mean that it goes to the
regular we don't how does this staff
pick what would be a scrap swarthy
material because I think that many
people would possibly like to see behind
the scenes material more I agree person
on YouTube whose name I can't pronounce
good there's too many characters um I
enjoy those very much those little
scraps are fish they are very yeah
everybody at their most real it's fun to
see Conan's real reactions to stop
whether he likes it or hates it know
here we go has anyone ever told you that
you look like Bobby Cannavale is that
for I'm not sure with that sport that's
for me or you it would be for you I
think at all is not a heavyset guy Bobby
Cannavale no I don't think in base to me
look like Bobby had about is your work
stressful Roberto be s wants to know not
usually sometimes sometimes
Oh Alex Larson says the scraps montage
was amazing you know what I just saw
that people should go on youtube and
watch the scraps montage because I just
saw it I haven't seen in alright our
digital team put that together and it's
really really funny it's really like Oh
crazy explosive it's got the beloved way
thing in it it's got the Tony the
cameraman sketched that has no ending
and Conan just giving you a hard time
but up up point it has him reacting to
del finiti for the first time and us you
know tuxedos when it oh when we yeah
when we did that once again this one
schedule so it was so dumb we didn't
know how it was gonna go the other
writer Dan had this idea that we would
wear tuxedos to rehearsal so that when
the sketch was over they could just cut
to us in tuxedos like like we just done
something very important it's really
like these good things are coming
do you ever present a fake script to
Conan just to trawl someone named vo
Brahma choco we talk about it all the
time all the time we like doing another
hole a rehearsal that will just be there
to dry you just never had the guts to
besides that's a lot of work for
something that's not actually gonna make
the show yes I love the latest minty
scrap I don't remember which one that
was oh I do remember that was one with
Jack and Brian thank you
oh here's another mole booster that was
a really funny scrap Conan's
relationship with Jackie's really is
very very interesting to watch it's very
abusive
oh my prayer yeah yeah the nicest guys
ever this is called oceanhorn
destroyer of jars oh we got macro
numbers necklace oh you're good at this
I'm sure you know what you're doing what
is your favorite food Mateo Lazaro ass
my favorite food is lasagna thank you
for asking
[Music]
I also like I also like cow soy which is
a Thai dish it's really really good I
heard that : let you guys drink during
work Raging Bull 34 says that that's
true
we drink all the time during work no no
good tone I guess we could but we don't
we occasionally very rarely will oh and
someone wants to know if there going to
be any more camera Tony the cameraman
sketches that is a question I'm sure
he'll come back
you saw the right for and easy to
because it's just me talking talking QM
Heisenberg asks what is your favorite
field of science cryptozoology
what is yours Andre - mine is a stroke
cryptozoology okay yep space make you no
space big booty yeah like the space
blackness I guess just astronomy like
space someone asked what type of lasagna
I thought lasagna was a good enough
answer for people food me I'm gonna say
bolognaise that's a good I love I love
pasta I love I love making it love
eating it we should come to Morocco
Hamza I've been to Morocco right now
yeah I figure the whole point of this
was to get the sword in the shield and a
necklace bird birds someone asked is it
true that most comedians suffer from
depression Shinobi 0:06
that's a very poignant question o-p-s
where's Conan I would say that I
definitely I would say suffer from it
but yeah I I definitely get depressed of
the navigate around depression I would
say I have yet to have to take any kind
of medications but who knows maybe
someday I'm taking one I'm very happy
with it hey I guess it's working if I'm
happy with it
it's Ted Turner coming back I don't
think so
probably not it's been a long time
begone and will forte is probably good
he's doing very well for yourself our
favorite hot sauce great question Alex
lassen Cholula I forgot what the brand
is involved but I think it's a Thai
brand mr. Raja so I love sriracha but
it's like he's got like search with a
gene I think
jinda or something like that can one of
you help us out
someone says Daniel I don't know on
YouTube says what type of depression he
really wants to mix it up this guy you
really wants to get into it
well Daniel not manic I have a kind of a
low-grade depression you can kind of
live with it yeah like a simmering yes a
simmering depression like a fog
occasional ideation just sort of like a
roiling fog that obscures your better
judgment from time to time
yeah kind of rude to play a game while
we're talking to you super 1077 I agree
we should just be talking to you all
right kill some punisher crabs somebody
else Madeline the IMS on twitch says
what's your favorite type of cloud
cumulus what's yours Andre I don't know
what names correspond to what shapes
Nimbus Stratus this strategy type of
cloud baby is it cumulus Nimbus and
Stratus okay someone's getting your
thumbs up so those are your three you
can pick but I've already picked cumulus
which shape is like the really gigantic
mush there you go cumulonimbus sure I'll
go with that
waffle tarts great answer do we hang out
with Andy or Conan after work or never
update
okay I'm gonna hear more skits with corn
and OH
unlike tools come to Colorado [ __ ] but
I don't think we've done them since The
Tonight Show it's been in probably ten
years S&M Lincoln was a mechanic's
character right yes yes we can't
character from late night another guy we
miss you
let's see someone's saying I have to
read in front of my congregation help
any advice this is from QM Heisenberg
are you having a Bar Mitzvah um I I mean
I would just say don't look down at the
page too much like know it well enough
that you can look at the congregation
every now and again my goodness is that
really taught 11 or is it Fred Armisen
throwing us how dare you oh yeah can I
thousand two I kind of know about what
I'm doing anymore other than hanging
around the beach killing crabs
the idea is oh wait there's like a man
Oh Madeline Sims sorry Madeline tips
thank you for asking that question about
clouds she's on twitch Madeline what is
your favorite rock type igneous
sedimentary is it is it a metamorphic
metamorphic right I miss McKenna who
Aaron Wallis no sedimentary it's
sediment it's layers of sediment that
are filled up in and compressed
sedentary means it's not moving it's
rock sedentary yeah bleh thought
sedentary was paper Brock what
indefinite is haha I didn't swear oh
I've been told to tell you our time is
up
farewell everyone okay gang this is five
o'clock and it's time to check in with
Conan thank you for enduring us hey it's
five o'clock five o'clock in the
afternoon technically this is the time
of day when it's okay to have a drink
I'm depending on your fear of the right
age I'm not advising you to have a drink
I'm just telling you that in society for
a long time five o'clock was sort of
seen as like you
have a drink at five you can have a
cocktail or a glass of wine in five and
you're not an alcoholic now if you've
been drinking before this you're an
alcoholic but five o'clock this is the
time when you could have like a sip of
something you'd have a little something
and that's what sort of waspey rich
people do at five they have a little
cocktail you know and then they go well
well that's the only word they know
anyway that's just a little advice I
don't recommend you drink but whatever
so it's five son getting lower towards
the west I bet you my digital team is
gonna say coming these little things
will you break in they don't have to be
as long as you're making them and they
really should have a little more content
and that's where I say hey punks I
invented the Internet okay no one's
hipper and cooler than I back off get on
your skateboards don't throw shade at me
Tyga
I'm not blac Chyna so as you can tell I
know what's going on have a drink if
you're old enough just a little bit
responsibly
hey everybody welcome back to the
24-hour team cocoa mobile marathon
sponsored by Google Play were played a
bunch of amazing great mobile games and
you guys are here with us until noon
tomorrow that's news Pacific Pacific
that's 3 p.m. on the old East Coast in
Mountain that's probably about a 2 p.m.
situation I'm not sure with mountain
times on Thank You Todd Levin and Andre
do BJ our writers you guys can clap if
you feel like it and coming up next
we're gonna have some three right three
great stress staff members coming up I
had to play a little a little bit of a
smarter game a little bit more educated
game we're gonna raise the bar a little
bit but before we introduce these fine
fellows and fine lady let's meet them in
this remote the staffer furlough remote
you guys remember when the government
shut down and they had to determine
which were the essential employees and
which weren't well these are some
essential employees take a look at this
remote good evening I'm Conan O'Brien
president of the Conan show as you know
we face a government crisis as we tape
this segment right now our government
has shut down and all non-essential
personnel have been furloughed they've
been laid off well I thought in keeping
with the times and to support my country
I should probably also lay off all
non-essential personnel here at the
Conan show by the way I'm wearing this
Guinness top right here this little
fleece in the hopes that Guinness will
see it and give me free Guinness what
are you doing right now
simple things what is it for sandwich
shop ok is this something that I asked
for is this for me so this is a sandwich
that would be for you
yeah it's a pie you weren't buy a pie
you want to buy a pie for yourself so as
I'm looking for whose nonessential I
come across you and you're what is it
buying a pie online my duties are to
help you and assist you in your life
seriously no to assist me in my life in
your work in personal life
would you say that you are essential
personnel Sona what's the deal here are
you doing a crossword puzzle on your
desk uh no this is your handwriting yes
and this is a crossword puzzle and I'm
sitting on your desk so you were doing a
crossword puzzle on your desk don't you
can't lie in front of the camera you
can't lie what are you stuck on what's
the word yeah give us the just tell us
which one it is I see and then you know
this ends up on the thing then people
are gonna be I'm stupid for not knowing
it so I just don't want it okay okay a
three-letter word for vehicle that
starts with C is car I assist the
executive producer what kinds of things
do you assist him and doing just winning
his life hoping answers phones emails is
there anyone here on staff what you
think is non-essential if you had to
give up one name who do you think is
non-essential anthe think about it yeah
Jordan Jordan is non-essential yeah
wieck's
what does he do I don't know I just
always see him filling up his Brita so
if I was to let someone go and staff you
would recommend that it is George leaves
me and you don't feel at all guilty
giving up his name we ask you is there
one non-essential person on the staff
someone who you feel probably doesn't do
that much and could be eliminated
just one yeah if I think the head you
had to right yeah I mean I don't even
know what he does it must be a real
douche you describe your duties on the
show please uh I overlook the whole IT
infrastructure that's a big ball
overlooked IT infrastructure that you
get your email describing his staff is
non-essential don't be afraid to give a
name
think about it non-essential
non-essential who could go if they had
to go beyond just be really honest
there's a name that popped into your
head he's my friend who is it
I say join us like oh no one is prompted
in any way this is the name this is
unbelievable so George less he is the
name that you use my buddy
yes nearly man I hope you and I are
never good friends where's Kramer you
just been downstairs you went downstairs
yeah I'm looking for a non-essential
personnel my guess is when someone's not
at their desk they're probably
non-essential would you agree I guess so
yeah you just sold out the guy you sit
next to it yeah
Jordan yes please stand
you and I have talked many times over
the years but this is serious okay I'm
talking to everyone on staff one name
has come up repeatedly I believe nine
times people don't know what you do
they don't understand your job you fill
your Brita filter with water is this in
fact the water that's often being filled
in the hallway the choice to remain
hydrated doesn't imply that I have no
work to do
how much is what do you think today
seventy eight ounces what are you a
weeping willow here are you a tree
that's a ton of water how much of this
day are you urinating then how many
times you go to the bathroom drain you
ideally once an hour you urinate once an
hour why ideally once an hour well I
have to make sure my urine is almost
clear you drink 78 ounces of water a day
after you more than seventy eight ounces
of water a day I drink 78 ounces of
water while I'm here how much what are
you drinking add a double 78 correct you
drink a hundred and sixty some odd
ounces of water a day
156
every time I ask you what you do and
we've had numerous remotes where I've
talked to you numerous times you use the
word numerous various assorted but you
never give one specific thing what do
you do if you're not gonna tell me who
are you going to tell the people that
need to know already know what do you
mean that's me
Jordan are you essential yes or no yes
were you to disappear now man is it
tempting would the show be affected with
the exception of yourself I could argue
that any particular staff member can be
eliminated with no visible results on
air you have the body languages Lee
Harvey Oswald welcome back everyone to
the 24-hour mobile marathon sponsored by
Google Play uh without further ado
please welcome through my favorite
people it's to Chris's and a Jemma Chris
Hayes Chris Brinson a gym Apollo get on
here you guys let's come from background
we got everybody you guys wanted to play
a little game called sparkles let's get
into it truly action there we go I
explain what you have here and say hello
people Chris Hayes here this is the two
time Bar trivia trophy that I happen to
be a member of so probably Conan Conan
Konya Bar trivia get on two winning
teams I'm Chris hi nice to meet y'all
hi I'm Gemma team Chris Hayes do the IT
work around here
so cool
yeah using try some trivia let's do some
trivia
it's just triangle Bell guy this is yeah
we're gonna test our hand at some trivia
here so feel free to join in we may feel
miserably at this I've never had this
much pressure this is what it's like to
be on a game show can't probably can't
mention the name of the show yeah it's a
lot of pressure here yeah go ahead let's
let's can we uh yeah let's do this can
you name the classes TV show when given
three words related to it we'll give it
a try let's go see the show let's well
it's already looking like a Mickey Mouse
Club nice let's see it's been a long
time actually Manhattan maybe earlier
today huh just looking at some of the
comments there it's all right here none
of this is real
will is adopted what would that be
what's my Willis Oh Diff'rent Strokes
thank you booyah eighties kit Diff'rent
Strokes Gary Coleman yeah that was good
so this is generally dummy yes oh yeah
this is San Fran aside how do you I
haven't had them yet
I know I can't say I can't speak of what
you're talking about but I haven't tried
them yet I wish I could I wish I could
I'm being paid and peanuts over here not
not fries I wish I was ah let's go next
let's see here does anyone have any the
answer is seven try seven yeah sure is
Oh different strokes someone else got
that one we can peanuts peanuts is what
I get Bob Bob Newhart show herself thank
you thank you miss miss mad face
this mattress this is mrs. manface thank
you for that right off
look we're all playing together raw help
one each one teach one each one region
one button oh listen I gotta make sure
it's on so it's still okay sorry guys I
have to check my phone because No
[Music]
Battlestar Galactica yes I used to wear
the red dress yeah Friday detectives
this guy's totally snooping through
worth emails and screen watching
employee is really demeanor for you guys
I wouldn't never do such a thing I would
never do such a thing
Friday Friday I thought it would they
were gonna be like ice cream with smoke
dragnet nice is this good DeLonge this
is Columbo
all right look really someone said
Fraser do we already hear Fraser
Frasier's know something say Fraser
I think I don't know dragon Astra Nelson
is Gemma an actress she live really
looks like Robinson one day she is
RuPaul's Drag Race they're just throwing
ourselves I Dream of Jeannie are they
say spydra and Jeannie right there hey
what's with the JLo Renee and I know
well it can't be Jeannie like the actual
Jeannie right maybe
yeah Wow which one of them was the
oldest and I am
yeah Conan's actually Laura Minnesota
and Ellie yeah oh come on guys help us
out cuz we're gonna have we're gonna
need you guys here yeah we're gonna need
we're gonna need you Laura
Minnesota Nellie Prairie who called that
one thank you
waffle time before I did this thing
right now I wanna and some bacon which
is why I'm having like the meat Swiss
right now gluten-free waffles what else
we got bus sewer Alice you guys feel
free to chime in
spongebob look you know you just get
down okay you know if we don't know that
ones answers sleeps at portal Oh lost in
space
yeah right no no that's a no Lena
belongs sorry Lana the loss that's what
I meant
yes know something starts hmm it's ah
the cracks is quite nice
incredible incredible no Cole just hold
it up laundry so we've been happy about
that
welcome back are you raised monkeys
monkeys little muffins chips the monkeys
someone is family om o NK EES oh you're
right
oh they're right it is how about the IT
guy watch this at work no one I ever
know no one will ever know ah the hope
max we play H cute yeah we're gonna risk
it high quality stuff we got 20 26 25
don't know go down to the next 100 yeah
you're right oh I'm American something
three two how about work that Conan how
many of you worked to Conan this will be
better with the people from the show for
what eight years now at this point eight
years nine years somewhere around there
it's been a long time I'm growing gray
hair so I'm getting a lot older now
yeah yeah yeah and I got graham Ripley
alright let's go let's go countries
after P and Q rhymes with Bob you can do
it that's telling us what this person
will top three scores by season no one
likes Arsenal huh what what should we
play how did you get your drop here uh
how did I get my job here I I got
brought in as an accountant which is
what I do here at Conan moneymaker money
man animaker money because I knew the
head accountant and she hired me it's
quite easy in here for about five years
original Starbucks flavors huh and you
name a pair of customers that start with
our given pairs letter on the given
continent oh yeah okay let's see Africa
can use name Kirk Oh Algeria Algeria
right yeah and Angola Angola nice good
call man
yes South America Brazil we got yeah all
right Bolivia Bolivia actually South
America Chile to a and uh somehow I did
not do cone instead
that sounds really hard Jordan make I
don't think anybody knows no one knows
first we gotta figure out what Jordan
does before he can figure out yeah how
much he may implicate it you have to map
the after match Colombia yeah
funny thing Colombia Africa Djibouti
Djibouti that's really excited
huh B Djibouti Dhabi the capital of
Djibouti Oh
frats okay I'll take it
are we running out of time yeah 4
minutes 30 see Europe France inland
Finland of course yeah of course of
course family might do that North
America Guam has to be right no no oh
and maybe that's a territory isn't it
what Imola that's that Guatemala yeah I
was so confident with the WHA overly
confident the beatnik says it's Pelican
Oh a half me IT guys North America H
Honduras Honduras I'm missing the last G
so I'll throw out that last G for us
please
Honduras Honduras Haiti carne de Haiti
yeah
fragile song coming strong who called
the Grenada the fragile spear well
fragile spear yeah we appreciate that we
need all that I don't know if it's a
special bond with the Japan sure nothing
what's another job in Japan
guys this is fun thank you thank you for
helping us out
clearly we need everybody likes trivia
everyone likes trivia we all just want a
second collectively we can all feel
smart with one another um what's the J
anyone come there the capital Greenland
is Denmark
someone said yeah we have did they
well sorry let's try over Laos la la oh
yes Jordan Jordan everyone keeps asking
about Jordan I know now we get to put
his name in okay right yeah what's the
other L we got we have Laos and I was
joinin shlonsky yeah Jordan they store
that's right Malaysia
no no if we're in Oceania yeah no
Marshall Islands that's a random one huh
I don't know I heard it somewhere
[Laughter]
time to call in bar gym team member
didn't do it all by myself took my team
I'd like to give a shout out what's
another
Oh Michael meet whoa oh bloody Nick's
coming strong huh
what was it Micronesia I wasn't going in
that direction it's in and Norway people
on a staff from the Netherlands we do
yeah lighting yeah oh yeah yeah good guy
good people ports or Portugal let's
become a jock geography lesson at this
point towards Portugal and Poland Poland
uh somewhere I would like to visit
Monday Poland Poland yeah okay I got a
cousin there he'll take care all right
Warsaw right that's where I want to go
yeah uh Rwanda I'm guessing I think
we're almost there guys we have 36
seconds left
then I spill rewards yeah it's like
there's no tuna wander huh fat though
yeah
very fat thumbs Rwanda another art yeah
anything rodizio that's that's a good
one that's right I can't Oceania Asia
who's Becca sneeze Becca stand there
that is that's going it was back oh
listen guys we are we got 25 out of 34
correct republicano Russia Spain yeah we
got we got democratic I knew I knew
there was gonna be that that country
throwing out there of course how could
it not be
that's a leak how could it not be
dealing with you people out there listen
everyone
let's take a category what is your job
title mine yes associate what is your
job entail yeah this one right here this
right here let's do one word admittedly
out of Harry Potter see too many movies
anyone the Star Wars crawl spam Utah
Oceana I don't know this year two
thousand seven hundred odd that's not
this year that's last year oh yeah I
won't be doing no no you guys go ahead
though I want to see well probably the
typers
what do you guys think movies come on
throw something out the box up laughter
let's see what happens let's name some
movies from last year okay no
essentially what happened here oh oh
person the movie is so Star Wars Vin
Diesel something with a has to be
something about driving computing the
Beast
yeah fast in the Furious part 25
I'm Honda spider-man yeah what was it
furious people- the Furious yes of
course but that might be isn't great
Oh guardians to you might be guardians I
don't think he said that G could be that
G and J in this cut nothing for you
wonder wonder what mechanism I am
terrible at movies Johnny Depp did that
do wise yeah to Justice League all right
dude
you're just showing off now I just I saw
Bennett Oh was dunkirk in there no no
there's a in yeah there is right was it
in there yeah sure be that's all I
needed man that was my fault that's my
wind right now Alec Baldwin I like so
are we talking about Alec Baldwin or
Alex real careful huh
Michael Bay well transformers again
yeah skarsgård is it who's like five uh
that works Oh pirates hi that's some hot
that's some high quality I love high
quality h2o as a matter of fact minions
oh yeah look I'm gonna I'm gonna let you
guys help me look smart battle for the
Planet of the Apes
Coco Coco right yeah I have a trial
which isn't us which could have minutes
I haven't tried them yet I wish I remind
you right I tried that
oh it didn't work didn't door out there
nope
did you try it or someone's gonna throw
out something I'm going to fall for it
[Music]
Oh remounting we got ya
Oh cream oh I hear you I see you got
Logan they're really helping us out
what's been diesel help us out what's
been diesel someone type in their VD and
then the name of the failed the furious
that was it who was fantastic there's
808 oh yeah yeah of course is the fake
horse well Steve Carell is Steve Carell
and that's what the star movie that's
what the star means
really I make a lot of things up all
right guys we have 49 seconds left with
triplet triplet Arsenal coming real wolf
wolf wolf warrior calm caps they're
angry they're mad at us who comments are
you listen guys it's a lot of pressure
one so then I thought it would be like
accepted this job we had no idea 10
second all the pump jack black is the
Polka came that was a good movie I saw
it yeah that was a good movie yeah
welcome to the jungle are not yelling I
know and you have a right to be
we understand we feel you're paying out
if I was in your seats I'll be doing the
exact same thing do some science we have
these smart people on the other side no
this actually might be kind of
ridiculous and fun oh no no no no
pictures there we go
can you name things yeah let's go okay
well is not which tree-dwelling North
American mammal has a fox like face of
the black mask yeah it's trash panda Oh
raccoon yeah yeah Ram RAM which large
deer lives in a subarctic region of
Eurasia in North America
reindeer Jim isn't by what other name
can the mountain ash be known as that's
a you know this can only start with art
uh mountain ash name is given to a
mammal that ferments its food and a four
chambered stomach a mountain ash when he
was going to die the recovers game
that's a retriever Panda I don't think
so no such thing as a red panda is there
I'm gonna tape it but no yeah you know
the summer's over abandon you bought it
what do you see a Rottweiler large rock
yeah it has to be you got forgot the tea
do it autocorrected in row boiler that
is a large flightless bird of South
America is related to the ostrich and
the EMU stop everything everything in
this starts with in our yeah I think
they know no now we're getting like all
type of different animal room and then
Rowan was looming out yeah I like that
that's now smart the room in it rhinos
with the four stuffed with the four
stomachs yeah choose their cud right oh
yeah rattlesnake someone throughout
rattlesnake up there sorry yeah it's
more fun that way oh this is true this
is what name is given to add red grape
rosemary rosemary oh it's not all
animals
rosemary ray fish fish isn't yeah what's
what
which swamp grass that was me Oh blowing
up birth redbreast don't know twice
right recruits person I know that did
someone say tonight I pin rook we're
doing that rodent rodent Jordan Jordan
Jordan lettuce rodent radicchio yeah
ah see and they're yelling it at
radishes everyone that yells we're just
gonna radishes Oh Raven you got Raven
Robin no rice rice that's right yeah
absolutely right buddy thank you well
done thank you crazy
I know what your name is hooking I just
can't say it like that I just can't see
it I was like this you got try rabbit
okay yeah Rottweiler we're still having
trouble spelling some rhubarb yeah there
you go thank you
virtual virtual one well done what are
we missing
what are we missing we'll miss really
need to March flightless bird of South
America is related to the ostrich in the
II might have no idea does anyone know
that the South forget it's coming in
slow the South we need it
what's the other ones which deer like
South African antelope has a woolly
brownish gray hair and straight or
it's gonna be something Bock right
because like Springboks and then they
have you know Bok Bok
we're not gonna know something we got
Rottweiler yeah they promise you
somewhere I promise you know what this
is bringing everyone the large
flightless bird that starts with an hour
all right we may have to tap out dude so
did a roadrunner but there's not on
there no that's not it
yes Oh Zeebo what someone had something
I don't want to read anything out in
case I mean there's a Reebok and array
raised yeah someone put Reebok young
guns see I did not say Bach yeah you did
I told I knew it was gonna be something
back you mocked me for the Bach you
wanna see mark the bottom you don't mock
my block you never mark the box all
right let's go get some people that this
alright let's find something new we
clearly need them you want super-science
let's move on this trophy's gonna zone
history guys yeah what's that some
history let's do some history okay what
do you want what do you want
or should we do some gaming since this
is it okay someone wanted in and then
see actually someone wanted in in the
natural world history of 2007 I get I
get what you gotta say the game stuff is
lured games in the toy Hall thing yeah
I'm into that
okay Howard did country is on target
okay
oh yeah this will be fun yeah yeah this
will be fun monopoly has to my name
monopoly
Alexander you didn't MooMoo Polly please
say my name Alexander
was a 2003 ancient Egypt I you guys are
giving us more happiness they were
giving you also we're getting a lot out
of this appreciate it there
all right we're gonna go with the we got
to go with the sorry I'm sorry
no no a risk
definitely a risk no what may be a clue
clue clue lose last year
classic what's the name of the game
again hold on here's what's gonna be
funny
Scrabble now if this is right this is
pretty cool it's like some inception
type stuff okay so mr. someone
throughout the game of life Oh guess
battleship battleship even if it's not
it definitely yeah should be what did
you throw out there battleship chutes
and ladders got threw it out there
listen we're taking suggestions well
it's on there back to the ancient India
gents something today
what's the asterisk me than that though
they probably don't know who exactly and
then did you do trackers it's all fake
checker said she's dead right tactical
study yellow try sorry sorry fellow sir
no sir
[Music]
it's a Dungeons & Dragons indie e ons we
got one out of eight what is showing
listen guys gotta go let's go let's go
all right let's see what else we got
that was good that feels good when you
get a full victory like keep mixing it
up we were inching towards the perfect
game and we finally achieve mean do you
think let's go just for fun that's
starburst flavors weren't in a word no
no let's do something where people can
actually chicken or beer no that's gonna
say chicken grab back absolutely there's
snifter Harley Quinn essence grabber who
said it Charlie Brown or Radiohead do
sports sports sports do some sports what
do you want to do I don't know just pick
one and the worst
salsa's teams to Mexico I think this is
gonna have some some red herrings in it
no Orleans we have six distance from
next to me a break stern you wanna bail
teams name of the teams
510 miles Texas Texans Cowboys Rams
raus good car Rams
yeah both la to you Oh - now charges she
caught it yeah charges no we took San
Diego a little oh we had to do that and
under Oh
strength you guys didn't give us the
answers quickly enough yeah and I also
don't type fast enough no they get a
little angry when we okay that's good
you guys are give us some great a store
another one out there never reload on
five English sports teams yeah yeah we
need we need a another member you know
let's see myth miscellaneous
miscellaneous what's holiday oh we could
do holidays are you smarter than a
college student $36 off well we could
try let's do it
all right should have done it without
where is he when is he yeah he was going
to be here as well oh we're on the clock
we're on the clock
we have 649 we have what school kids a
garden or the kinder Garten are you for
real
that's the easy is the easy sorry yeah
the typing on this is gonna be hard why
is that cuz I don't spell so guts
harder oh is it that easy common term
for 2000 no that's why I spelled wrong
with arthritis Mozart Mozart thank you
sir sir roll quarter Hogwarts
Jennifer move is big words Oh hIgG words
martini
we got a martini coming teeny Bart flash
of the day what oh yeah earth as far as
I know is that apartheid AP I don't say
it now spell hey yeah whoopee AR th yeah
they ID card
PID just keep saying it
ah thank you
hey sir is on his game you're on top of
your game um let's see
artery because it has to be one of them
right that's the what type of blood
vessel carries but away from the heart
artery artery artery Oh artery keep
saying it's right there maybe you should
is Pumbaa in the Lion King we're looking
that you got a board
he's board a board oh excuse me
what yes tartar sauce tartar sauce
what Reagan
Ford and Reagan Carter yeah it is the
name of the main temple to athena atop
the across you know that I know you
you know man we were looking we look we
looking real smart right in the right
about now oh it did not said no what
didn't give it to me darkness what gave
me torque what gaming target has a
dartboard man dart node I don't know
there's a big is it dart I Pantheon hold
on oh yeah oh the Parthenon yeah
Dartmouth dartboard huh
they're good very good someone said
article you already said artichoke
there's even a typo cup without hearthat
on all right
Damascus well I don't even know who
where their Wedd what is capital city of
sisian is it
[Music]
like here nope my brain just shut yeah
man this is yeah this all started
bleeding together I mean we can always
give up you know Artemis that one nice
doesn't like it brand of candy what is
the term feel radder Oh handspring with
arms and legs extended that's that's the
word I was looking for
it is good at lateral alright yeah that
we're Duff some of these are pretty
tough there's a fourth musketeer Aramis
out with us Aramis in the Dumas Lovelace
was divorced Mouseketeer you asking me
to spell d'Artagnan is gonna be tough Oh
carp carps KH 8 RT oh um no that's gone
hmm
what sweet hurry RTO you remember this
can you take away taking away don't play
sports
do it well you know what let's go to the
next one Matt let's go to this is not
our best story I found it what was that
the K okay the K Oh
I'm just typing things that people are
saying because they're way smarter than
well we need you we need your help we
need your Hatton mmm you should not
world war two five-star general said
well there's so many out there that's
the one that I was - cartoons yeah I got
it for us the world war ii general
eisenhower was it nice in our
sweethearts please sir I know I know so
far all right that's we got 40 more
seconds right we'll go for one will go
for four minutes
was it MacArthur no MacArthur maybe we
tried some put out robert e lee that was
a good thing that was I think is that he
was a little bit ahead of you got 26 out
of 30
it wasn't MacArthur we just misspelled
it sharks room he went with the M AC
room
the typical M sent Edith Wharton he
wasn't just a noisy chartreuse yeah
alright let's go for the next one done
we're just gonna keep going yeah we got
yeah what do you guys want let's see
dog breeds by anywhere that's going to a
different what dog breeds
do you know briefed on her dog three
we're gonna get a shot 194 no no when
walking away
I'm score zero of 194 we did the best we
could
yeah we did the best we could let's do a
geography one can do some geography
let's go let's go this skewer knowledge
of the US country's closest to pull okay
going keep going
route 66 days blueberry State couch
cheese after F&J yeah that's right I
think it'll be short sorry sweet short
and sweet
yeah give a shout cut Oh
right Oh Oh
Fiji we're doing this oh yeah any
country right right so like France is
one it has those letter combinations
right you see jail Jordan giant she's
killing it four of eight by the way
we're killing this one uh Afghanistan
would be the F and G feel good about
that one I think my job is done
well his job is FD we need the FT
Afghanistan we got you on that one
it's filled out yeah yeah GH oh you guys
all right FA Faroe Islands Thank You
Internet
well he's not on the 5 T yeah yeah yeah
yeah and offensive a leave no me just
types numbers and that's that's good
enough for us around here everyone
appreciates Chris Brinson for that
without him no one gets this is
literally worth nothing no the falklands
not it
no that no that's those were that was a
territory of great britain right
remember the war was fine yeah
the Argentinians get upset seriously FDA
has to be aft it has to be FT aft oft
right I'm feeling like those are two
words you see them saying like those are
yeah they just came for gaming news
routine FS oh okay what's the last one
25 seconds we need to have tea this
isn't gonna work
oh we have 19 seconds let's see if we
come through anaconda close yeah
yeah if only we'll kind of had an F T in
it you trap you would have probably been
right with that FTF TF t I'm drawing a
blank
what was it oh it's banana Genson an
again okay let's do another speed round
let's jump at it has to be it has to be
lettuce P and Q that was that was short
one so people do the one after P and Q
where is it live top keep going right
there countries after being Q weird
you're doing a fine job
I don't know we have not okay Paraguay
waffle tarts where do they get enough
Sabri gaming is pretty awesome too
we got the PE no we don't have the PE
Philippines pH I Airlines yeah Poland ph
IL i PP e there you go
any yes nice PT q are you did that one
cutter
no respect the queue I guess is just
ending Thank You Pete no but we have a
PE a PR Puerto Rico
yeah you know what this requires a lot
of rock yeah yeah yes we should have hey
it's six six o'clock we've now been
going for six hours man look at this
beard coming in I have no testosterone
see what seven
all right hey guys please it is 7
o'clock if you didn't have a drink at
5:00 you can definitely have a drink now
I know I'm a little obsessed with when
you get to the 24-hour mobile marathon
sponsored by Google Play let's hear it
for Chris Chris and Gemma you know
nobody's talking they don't wanna clap
great job guys I'm real dumb so that
would have been that's basically a
horror game I don't consider that a
trivia game for me that's a horror game
so speaking of horror what do you guys
think about this shirt right look at
this what are we in right now is this
our 7/6 anybody know I need no one no
one cares there's snacks over there
people are grazing it's crazy I think
this is the sixth hour and this is my
sixth costume change this is when you
can't decide between ugly plaid and ugly
camo get you a shirt that can do both
right hashtag waste of money we done we
done it we done it but you know what
account let's go this background with
these pillows so thank you all for
joining us if you're just joining us we
are playing our favorite games from the
Google Play Store until noon pacific
time tomorrow we need even half over
baby and i wore a watch or i can't even
see the hands why did i do that
for 24 hours i'm gonna stare at this
thing it's just a big black dumb dot but
so far we've played a bunch of amazing
games let's talk about them shall we
Monument Valley to Lumino City Game of
Thrones conquest we played that game I
mean I was terrible at it but
technically we played it played some
animal crossing pocket camp with Sonam
obsession and David hopping Konitz to
assistance and while that was happening
pretty sure Conan was just wandering
around the lot drooling on himself
hidden folks which is an amazing kind of
word Where's Waldo Adventure lineage to
revolution